but now we have to make a turn we're
talking about the fall we're talking
about apples you may have noticed you're
paying more for your apples this time of
year well the fruit is at the center of
many beloved Traditions like trips to
the orchard to the farmers market making
pies and for the people who grow them
and those who love to eat them this
Fall's Harvest comes with a set of
unusual challenges including including
inflation labor shortages as well and
those issues threaten to wipe Orchards
out Scott McFarland has more
Baron Shaw runs a family farm in apple
orchard in York County Pennsylvania
they got its start in 1841 so it's
striking to hear Shaw say he's facing
challenges this year unlike any year
before how stressful is that for you try
to get through your business and through
the week inflation makes it very
stressful I mean the fuel prices the
energy costs all of it is going up
inflation is squeezing industries of All
Sorts but for this delicate industry
which produces this delicate fruit
they're seeing a perfect storm down the
supply chain that's hitting Growers
heart
you don't go into this business unless
you've got a lot of faith a lot of faith
in God a lot of faith in the family
members around you and um you know
that's what keeps me going unlike so
many other items in the produce aisle
that benefit from automated farming
practices
apples are picked by hand and require
intensive specialized labor to harvest
Shaw says they can't find domestic
workers for this intensely physical job
the industry relies heavily on
International migrant laborers using h2a
visas their wages are set by the federal
government and varies state by state
every year that price goes up and up and
we don't have a whole lot of say in that
so we just have to pay pay what the
government tells us that's out of your
control completely out of our control
Shaw saw the wage for h2a workers
increased 10 percent from last year up
to 15.78 cents an hour and across the
country h2a wages have been going up
five to ten percent every year the U.S
Apple industry Association estimates
total labor costs have spiked 30 percent
this year how do you plan one year five
year ten years in the future it's a very
challenging issue right now
apples on average cost six percent more
this year that's not all because of
Labor in fact most Farmers aren't seeing
more money in their pockets so it's
inflation that's causing some of the
industry's biggest customers to see the
most dramatic effects about 1500 to 2
000 apples a day to serve our kids you
need 2 000 apples a day a day a day to
meet our needs in Montgomery County
Maryland this is the first year ever
Public Schools won't be able to serve a
fresh seasonal Apple for lunch local
apples this fall cost them three times
as much they'll have to stick with
cheaper pre-packaged slices instead less
Apple for each child how important
is an apple to a kid apples are our
number one fresh fruit that our kids
love whether it's a whole apple or apple
slices number one choice and that's
Pre-K to 12th grade
for Farmers like Baron Shaw to weather
this economic storm they're trying to
lure you to buy at the apple orchard
itself this fall to cut out the
middlemen they can offer a lower price
and land a bigger profit if you pick it
off the trees than off a grocery store
shell I am
two three
and for your local apple orchard that
could be the Tipping Point some Orchards
somewhere in America they can't sell
directly to people on their Farm they're
going to go out of business it's very
very possible yes these businesses
really are not sustainable unless
they're profitable because there's
there's no reason for the Next
Generation to do this if they can't make
a living and can't make a retirement
doing it for CBS mornings I'm Scott
McFarland in Stewartstown Pennsylvania